do you have any favorite thinkers that
were kind of Inspirations for toe or for
for wanting to get into this or Donald
Hoffman was the reason the theories of
everything Channel started because he
was being interviewed and is still
interviewed on platforms where they just
asked him about the same questions over
and over and then it comes down to like
two statements oh look how foolish
materialism is and it's just like Diet
tribes on against materialism which is
most of the Consciousness podcasts or
most of the Consciousness explanations
and videos that I see that I see
personally and for me that gets tiring
after the first two little the 200th
right and then the second one is he says
space 's doomed I'm like okay come on
Donald like is is there any I I said
this joke that I love Donald Hoffman
because he's constantly saying new
things and by new things I mean he finds
50 different ways of saying SpaceTime is
doomed yeah and so I'm I'm thinking okay
given that he's predicating all this in
the papers which are math based why is
no one asking him about the math I can
go through that that's my background so
let me read the PDFs and then ask him
about that yeah what the heck does it
mean that this set is consciousness or
this this Markov chain one of these is a
conscious experience what does that mean
why does that necessarily translate over
to how we work evolutionarily or a
perception and does that also give rise
to Quantum Mechanics like he says so I
had all these questions and I can look
through and then I interviewed him
fairly technically and people seem so
that seemed to take off and so I was
like wow this is banging on all
cylinders cuz I've always been
interested in theories of everything
since I was since I I learned about them
and I like Puzzles and math and then I
went into film making but now I'm like
okay I can use film making meaning is
like video and I can use these these
analytical skills that I have or at Le
proclivities that I have and it's like
in the domain that I absolutely love oh
my gosh and I wouldn't say Donald is a
favorite thinker of mine but he's
responsible for the channel that's super
cool yeah well I'd love to actually get
a little deeper into his stuff because I
intuitively I sort of think that physics
is more the interface between biology
and like the inanimate world or
something than most hardcore physicists
would like admit that would be my bias
and so I've been fascinated and I'm sort
of like a fan of PlayDoh and I think we
see
Shadow play at the end of the day but
that's also kind of an intuitive gestal
feel on my part so I didn't realize so
he's fairly technical like he he he will
sort of technically back up this this
Theory yeah him and his co-authors one
is named oh I believe shatar shatar or
shakar anyway he he's a mathematician
that co-author and Donald is knows way
more math than he should for a computer
or for a cognitive scientist so Donald
actually has the chops that he's saying
much more than people can think much
more sorry much more than most people
know uhhuh interesting I want to go
through his his stuff do you salvator
Pas as favor guest he would be one of my
favorite guests okay interesting so do
you think after having interviewed P
once or twice now twice do you think
that these Navy patents are legit I
reserve judgment
so I I don't even think in terms of that
so that would be a question that I would
think for like 20 seconds and say I
don't know so I'm trying to not do that
right now yeah yeah do you think he's
after having spoken to him do you think
he's I mean it sounds like you do think
he's a rigorous thinker yeah I think
he's he's an extremely honest and
heartfelt person what I like about him
more than than his patents
is when I was interviewing him I asked
him I said so how put off and Eric Davis
and I think Jack s fatty said not
terribly nice words about your about
your patents so so what do you think
what do you make of their criticism and
he he just he sat there he's like you
know I think their ideas are worthwhile
and I just I don't know why they don't
think mine are but but people should
investigate theirs and I'm like oh my
gosh like one of the greatest stories
from the Bible to me is when Peter Jesus
was being taken away to be killed yeah
so this is like not even nonviolence
like the opposite of nonviolence like
way more nonviolent than nonviolence yes
Peter cut off the ear of the person
who's taking Jesus to kill him and then
Jesus like don't do that and then he not
only said don't do that he took the ear
and healed it on the on the person who's
taking Jesus away to kill him so Jesus
is like no no you love your enemy like
you feed your you feed your family and
your enemy before you even feed yourself
wow and and and you wash like on the
night that Jesus was going to die yeah
in the stories yeah he's washing the
feet of his disciples like doing the
most lest of tasks wow the night before
and he knew like in the stories that he
knows that he's going to die the next
day and he's like no this is still
important you humble yourself nothing is
beneath you wow and and this just like
gets gets me man like if I think about
that too much I just start to
to well to tear up yeah and so South Pi
like that love thy enemy that's like
something that I I hope to be motivated
by and I see that in him and that's what
resonated most with me that's amazing
that's super cool I love the episode you
did with him and Stefan Alexander he's a
really cool guy too yeah I was just
speaking of Jesus this is a a total
tangent but uh in the last week and a
half I just spent some time with Randall
Carlson um who works with Graham Hancock
he's a sort of geologist esot terorist
and then Brian mirescu who wrote this
book called The immortality key um which
is all about these like ancient mystery
rituals these linian mystery rituals
that took place in Greece and Socrates
Pythagoras Aristotle Plato they all went
through these things and both of them
agree this is kind of a heretical belief
they think that Jesus never died and
that if you read the text pilate who was
the governor of Rome or of that little
contingency of Rome at the time uh poked
Jesus's flesh with the spear
and it was to see whether he was dead or
not but they think maybe Jesus was given
a sedative and it was sort of either a
mystery ritual or he like faked his own
death and then he was put in a shroud of
like resuscitating herbs by this guy
Joseph of ARA and then he survived and
maybe even had a bloodline like in like
into today or something which is really
fascinating I don't know that's
definitely heretical yeah it's heretical
right yeah um so I I don't know but who
knows who knows yeah do you are you
interested at all in the Bible or or
anything I'm super interested yes yes in
the Bible but not just the Bible I don't
discount religion like I used to be this
inexorable uncompromising atheist yeah
from 8 years old yeah up
until a few years ago M yeah I was I
used to be a fan of like you know the
four horsemen uh Daniel Dennett right um
Sam Harris Christopher Hitchens who was
the fourth and the fourth Horseman and
uh Dawkins of course uh and they were
just you know like watch The God
Delusion and God Is Not Great and you
know all that stuff yeah it was great
and uh and then I started to
realize I don't know I just think
there's so much weirdness that we can't
explain to the world and even through a
physics lens like I'm interested in the
anthropic principle and sort of the
Goldilocks Environ that we live in and
to me that signals possible intelligent
design and anomalies and evolution as
well and so I don't know whether that's
God God to me is sort of a placeholder
term but something mystical and
intelligent have you heard of demsky no
so
demsky I have I would like to look
through this and by the way me saying
that I'm no longer this inexurable
atheist doesn't mean that I'm now this
devout religious person it just means I
don't deride the religious and I
investigate and take it seriously mhm
demsky has an argument based in math
which I would like to go through much
like Don like Donald Hoffman's which
Steven Meyer who's an proponent of
intelligent design uses which says I
think it says something like the search
space of DNA or
of the search space of evolution is too
vast to have outputed this complexity
this fast something like that totally he
uses something called the no free lunch
theorem or no free lunch theorems and
that is by David wpart who was a guest
on top and David walart has this whole
article saying like dempy misused my
arguments and he also used them in words
and he's like you need to make it
mathematically precise and they're two
types of arguments one where it's like
art and literature and and religious and
so on and that's a word type argument
and then there's like the domain of the
specifically defined which is
mathematical there are only few results
in the specifically defined and some
them are like girdles incompleteness
theorem and the no free lunch theorems
those are limiting theorems or no go
theorems but they're extremely powerful
because they're precise and he's like
his is in the just words arguments which
means you can't tell if it's true or not
true can't even make a decision right
that's what wallpart says so I want to
get wpart to talk with dempy on the
channel it out interesting so yeah true
just words it's like not even wrong or
something exactly exactly yeah
interesting if you enjoyed that clip
then the full podcast is out right now
you can click around here enjoy
subscribe to theories of everything to
get notified of upcoming podcasts as
there are new full length podcasts every
week on the topics of mathematics
physics Consciousness Free Will and
AI